مضى عقد على بدء الحرب المروعة
في سوريا ،
وقد دفع الملايين ثمن هذه
الحرب ، لكن الصراع كان
وحشيًا بشكل خاص بالنسبة للشباب السوريين
وفقًا لبيانات اليونيسف منذ أوائل عام 2020 ، فقد ولد
ما يقرب من
5 ملايين طفل في
سوريا
منذ بدء العنف المستمر.
مرة أخرى في عام 2011.
تعيش بشرى البالغة من العمر 11 عامًا
خارج مدينة إدلب
، وقد أمضت 10 من تلك السنوات الـ 11 في
منطقة حرب
من نواح كثيرة ، الحرب هي سوريا الوحيدة
التي عرفت
أنها أعطتنا لمحة عن يوم في
حياتها  من نواحٍ عديدة
تشبه الفتيات الأخريات في مثل سنها
حول العالم
[موسيقى]
أم
أه
[موسيقى]
على عكس العديد من الفتيات في سن 11 عامًا حول
العالم ، فإن أوشرا لديها مستوى إضافي من
الخوف تقلق عليه بشأن
سلامة أسرتها وسلامة  تمتلك
بين عامي 2014
و 2019 ما يقرب من 1000
منشأة تعليمية وطبية
تعرضت للهجوم بما في ذلك
مدرسة بشرى
[موسيقى]
و
[موسيقى
] تقدر وكالة اللاجئين التابعة للأمم المتحدة أن ستة
ملايين شخص في سوريا
قد أجبروا على ترك منزلهم  mes وهم الآن نازحون في البلاد ، تفيد أيضًا أن الصراع المستمر قد أدى إلى زيادة هائلة في القلق واضطرابات النوم التي يعاني منها الشباب الجادين [موسيقى] [موسيقى] [موسيقى] [موسيقى] [موسيقى] مع دخول الحرب العام الحادي عشر الذي تفاقم بسبب جائحة كوفيد -19 ، يدخل ملايين الشباب السوريين عقدًا جديدًا محاطًا بالعنف والصراع للأطفال مثل سلامة بشرى واستقرارها في سوريا لا يمكن أن يأتي قريبًا بما فيه الكفاية